we're from guinness world records and
this is our wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
we are going to be unveiling our
guinness world records 2023 edition
[Music]
so what guinness world records
what are some guinness world records
titles to break
we do have a database with over 60 000
records which means that we have
literally something for everyone we kind
of encourage people to
search through it figure out what
they're passionate about no matter how
unique and just kind of pursue it so as
guinness world records employees we
technically can't break records but what
we do do sometimes in the office is road
test so we like when we're opening new
record titles we'll just go ahead and
like try some i once tried uh
the most it was like the most cheeto
puffs eaten in three minutes and
unfortunately i could only do 20 which
felt very low but i was pretty proud of
myself what
do you get with a guinness world records
or a gwr well you get the pride and joy
of knowing that you've broken a guinness
world records title and you're the best
in the world at something
but you also get a really cool record
holder certificate with your achievement
on it and you get to join a really cool
community of record holders that are
really supportive of each other what are
the wackiest guinness world records
titles we recently verified the first
retractable lightsaber which was pretty
awesome
we also have kevin fast who breaks a lot
of records with us he's pulled so many
incredible items like an airplane a bus
my favorite kevin fast one is heaviest
uh sled pulled so he dressed up in santa
claus and pulled a sled with like
presents and stuff
which is really really cool yeah what is
the hardest gwr so i think it depends on
the skill level of the person of the
human whoever is doing the record
attempt it can range from eminem
stacking to
climbing the tallest mountain
surprisingly the tallest stack of m ms
you would think it's pretty easy
it's very challenging the current record
is
uh seven who guinness world records
who is the tallest person
in gwr so the tallest living man his
name is sultan kozin he's from turkey
and he is
over eight and a half feet so the
shortest living man is eduardo el nino
hernandez and he stands at two feet four
inches
who holds the gwr
for eating the most big macs so the
record holder for the most big mac's
eaten in a lifetime is donald gorski as
of december 2021 he has eaten 32
672 big macs
who holds the gwr for most languages
spoken so that as a category we have so
many different language records um the
most spoken
language by native speakers is actually
manned in chinese fun fact the most
widely spoken fictional language is
actually klingon so for the star trek
fans you guys are really making that
language circulate across the globe all
right
does gwr have anything to do with the
drink so it does sir hugh beaver who was
the managing director of the guinness
brewery in the early 1950s was part of a
hunting party and all of him and his
friends in the hunting party were
curious what the fastest game bird in
europe is and no one knew the answer
they went and they they went home they
checked
none of the reference books had it so
this gave him an idea a few years later
to create a book of fun facts to help
settle um pub disputes so that's where
the guinness book of records the
original version
came out of fun fact the first editions
actually had waterproof pages so this
way they were in the pubs and just in
case anything spilled on them or they
foul or anything they're pretty durable
and they can continue to help settle
those disputes does the
gwr have a database for every record
broken yes
we have a record database we have over
60 000 different types of records if
you're ever interested in applying to
like break a record you can visit our
website you can search the database
yourself and see all the different types
of records that are there and you know
pick one that you want to try
discuss world records reach out to
record breakers we do our in-house
research team will reach out to current
or potential record holders especially
if um there's something circulating in
the news or on social media but we
always say you don't have to wait for us
to reach out to you just apply for a
record just go for it okay guinness
world records
gwr man who ate a plane so we have a
title for the strangest diet and this is
by michael lottito i believe who was
from france he would eat metal and glass
he realized that he was able to do this
when he was having a drink of something
and the glass broke and then he was able
to
eat the glass so he continued with that
diet
through the rest of his life and he ate
over 200 pounds i believe of metal and
glass gwr fingernails
so our fingernail records are probably
one of our most iconic records they're
just an incredible beautiful piece of
art essentially for every person that
wears them i've had the honor of seeing
ayanna williams who was our former
record holder for the longest
fingernails on a pair of hands female
and they were absolutely beautiful
guinness world records the gw title for
the longest hair the longest hair ever
was a woman in china
who had been growing her hair since she
was 13 years old and then we recently we
just had a former record holder for
longest hair on a teenager
and that was uh nalanji melanchi patel
she's from india
and she had hair yeah i went like all
the way down to her feet she recently
just cut it off so she's no longer the
record holder so again yeah looking for
a record holder if you've got long hair
apply
guinness world records title for the
biggest poop uh so this is another one
that we don't monitor just really not
something that we could
verify uh
or standardize hygienically yeah
but there's plenty of other record
titles for folks to apply for so
there's no shortage
gwr quietest place on earth so the
quietest place on earth is a chamber in
microsoft's headquarters in redmond
washington and it is so quiet they've
set this up that you can't hear an echo
it is just completely silent it was made
i believe with several layers of
concrete and it has these pieces of
fiberglass that also break up the sound
waves so even if someone claps you don't
hear that sort of snap back afterwards
so it's pretty it's pretty interesting
if you're looking for a really quiet
room microsoft has the secret okay so
what guinness world records
[Music]
looks like what is the what is the
biggest dog in the world so the tallest
dog
um that has a guinness world records
title ever
is zeus he was a great dane and he
measured over 44 inches tall what is the
guinness world records title for the
longest fart
so we don't monitor this record so do
not feel free to apply for this one when
we open records we always have to have
certain record criteria so some of those
are like measurable verifiable
standardizable so in this case we would
not monitor this because we would not be
able to verify this accurately or
standardize it or standardize it
okay what is the
longest facetime call
we don't have a record for the longest
facetime call but we do have a record
for the longest telephone slash video
conversation for a team of two and that
one is 54 hours and four minutes imagine
talking to your boo for that long that's
that's a long time
what is the guinness world records title
for longest kiss we've got a few fun
ones for longest kiss we have the
longest kiss in apnea which is
underwater and that was over three
minutes long and then we also have the
longest habanero pepper kiss so you
actually have to eat the pepper but then
you have to kiss your partner no water
there's no water involved you gotta just
go go right into it so it's pretty
pretty impressive
what is the guinness world records title
for holding your breath underwater
underwater sorry
we don't measure records just for
holding your breath underwater but what
we do is we have uh records that you can
do underwater for example we have the
longest underwater walk in one breath
and the record for that is 350 feet so
the record holder was able to walk 350
feet underwater without coming up for a
breath which is
wow
yeah
all right how guinness world records
how many gwr books are there so there
are 68 editions of guinness world
records we are going to be unveiling our
guinness world records 2023 edition
so here is the cover um and fun fact the
2021 edition 2022 2023 and 2024
they're all a jigsaw so you can lay the
covers down on the floor and they all
connected are you serious yeah this is
pretty cool so if you like
if you if you kind of put it out like
that
they'll all connect so you can see
basically a universe of record breaking
which is pretty awesome how does gwr
make money we make money in a few
different ways we're excited to work
with businesses and organizations that
want to incorporate this record-breaking
fund into any of their plans guinness
world records the annual book is still a
bestseller globally it comes in 40
languages over 100 countries and we sold
over 1.8 million books
in 2021 alone we also produce tv shows
across the globe we also have a really
incredible social media presence across
facebook twitter snapchat tick tock and
we actually have over 70 million
followers across all of the accounts and
tick tock we have over 19 million and we
were one of the top three brands on
there how much
is a guinness world records title worth
a guinness world records title is pretty
priceless and there's nothing better
than telling somebody i'm the best in
the world
so
you know
priceless yeah truly priceless okay how
do animals win guinness world records
titles so we have a lot of different
records
that feature animals who are the record
holders they're done with the owners of
the animals you know helping them
achieve the record and they're all so
much fun i love them all the big thing
that we make sure is like when we're
working with animals or when animals are
going to break a guinness world records
title is that they remain safe the whole
time that they're never being forced or
pushed or exploited so we have a lot of
like big safety rules around that but
otherwise we're just happy to see all
the different kinds of things that
animals can do
there's some pretty cool ones like
you've seen um a dog and a cat ride a
scooter and um benny the bunny bitty the
money yeah benny holds the record for
the most basketball shots
in a minute i believe by a rabbit they
have seven they got seven shots in
guinness world records we really invite
people to like discover their world
whether that's through human body or
nature or skills or collections there is
something for everyone there and we want
to inspire the world to be a better
place and celebrate each other and you
can also learn a thing or two